alright let's get started welcome to the
session on JavaScript the cute parts my
name is Venkat Subramanyam we're going
to talk about some of the wonderful
features in JavaScript especially in es6
and some of the things we can actually
do a lot better well this time to ask
questions or make comments as whenever
you have it if you do have a question or
a comment I request you to start
speaking up I cannot see actually from
here because of the lights in front of
me but if used I draw my attention I'll
be more than happy to listen to you so
let's talk about just a little bit about
the good old JavaScript you know I was
thinking about how to describe
JavaScript as a language and can you
believe it this is 2018 and we are
talking about JavaScript and so here's
my definition of what JavaScript is it's
like that bad villain in the movie they
keep killing him but he keeps coming
back to life that's how it feels about
JavaScript isn't it but JavaScript the
old one was really notorious but here
we're talking about thankfully modern
JavaScript modern JavaScript is a lot
better
it's learnt a lot of things from a lot
of different languages for example
languages like Ruby and Java and c-sharp
and so on a lot of different languages
it's got inspiration from and there's a
lot of number of beautiful features in
fact I never thought I would get
actually excited about JavaScript but
honestly has to started playing with
JavaScript the modern versions I got
pretty excited about it so much that I
actually wrote a book on it call the
rediscovering JavaScript it's in a way
that it's really true that it's a
rediscovery because it's a language
that's been around for 20 plus years and
yet there is so much to really do with
that given the changes that the language
has gone through over the past you know
a few years so I want to talk on barbra
about what are the better things we can
do and I want to share with you some of
the parts I'm really excited about what
I call as the cute parts are things that
really are making a real life's a lot
better so let's talk about a few things
that we shouldn't do and we should
probably move towards doing the first is
we should really get rid of bar in the
code var is really a bad idea
so for
example if you save our max equal mm and
I want to print the value of max right
there but for reasons I don't understand
you could actually do var 200 and you
can print var what doesn't make sense
any sense here is that we are redefining
the variable one more time it makes no
sense at all to redefine a variable
hiding this particular variable at this
point not a very healthy thing to do but
also if you continue a little further
let's say we have a function right now
and within the function I'm gonna say
let's say local 1 and the local 1 is
equal to let's say a value of 7 and I
want to print out the value of local 1
as you can see right here and it printed
it but what I want to do here is to
define a block scope so within this
block I'm gonna say local 2 equal to
let's say a value of 8 and I'm printing
local 2 and that worked also but
unfortunately though at the time of war
JavaScript really did not have a block
scope so what JavaScript does is it
comes along nicely and says hey look I
found a little nice little braces and
throws it away it has no meaning at all
unfortunately so as a result notice I'm
able to use local 2 right outside of the
block scope which is pretty nasty so
these are some of the problems with var
so what do you do with var so the best
thing to suggest is a quit using var
because this is really not a good idea
at all so moving forward we should not
use var so what should we do instant
well let's get back to this code for a
second let's say use the let if you will
and I'm gonna say max equal to 1000 now
I'm gonna print the value of Max it's
1000 now I say let max equal to 200 and
I want to print the value of Max well
that will give an error as you can see
and the reason is you cannot redefine a
variable that's been defined using let
that's the really good news similarly if
I have a function called a flu and in
this function if I were to define let
let's say a local 1 is equal to 7 one
more time and I'm gonna
print local one and I'm calling the
function foo you can see that actually
work but if I were to put a block scope
and say local 2 equals to 8 and I'm
printing local 2 and you can see that in
this case if I were to try to access
local 2 outside that would become an
error as you can see I'm not allowed on
line number 10 to access the variable
because it's got block scope so the good
news is let has block scope and then of
course can't be redefined as well so in
other words what what I'm getting to is
quit using var so quit using var use let
but having said that I'm gonna change it
right away so don't use let as much as
possible so why not I'm gonna give you
an example of why let is not a smartest
thing on earth let's take a look at one
example real quick let's say for a
minute I say a factor equal to 2 for a
minute well that's great now I want to
say over here print it equal to and I'm
gonna take an element but I'm gonna
print out right here let's go ahead and
say in this case e times factor now of
course I'm gonna call print 8 pass a
value of 2 and you can see that the
value is 4 there's no surprise over
there but I'm gonna now go ahead and say
factor equal to 0 now honestly I'm gonna
ask you the question what are you how
many of you think the output is going to
be 4 just to show off hand
not a single person thinks it's a 4 how
many of you think it is 0
a few people raised the hand others did
not how many of you think I have no clue
absolutely I'm with you that's exactly
where I am - I have no clue well I work
with multiple languages this is way too
much then my smartness can help me and I
look at this I'm like huh what's this
happening well here is a beautiful thing
I often like to give this as an
interview question and I would give this
an interview question and ask the
developer what is the output if they try
to answer the question I tell them you
are fired
even before they are high
because the right answer is are you all
stupid to write code like this then
you're hired because the point is we
want to write code that's easy to work
with this is terrible code well as you
can see the result was zero but that's
really complex what should we do instead
well this is why we want to use a
constant instead because a constant
cannot be mutated notice in this case
when I try to run the code I get an
error on line number five saying that
line five says I cannot mutate the
variable because it's a constant so the
short answer is quit using so quit using
var that's a very first thing you sconce
TWEN
use let only where Const is not you know
possible so this should be the really go
to recommendation is quit using var use
constant wherever possible and use led
only when a constant is not possible so
your go-to should really be to use
constant I would in fact say that this
is one of the things we should do as a
coding standard in Java moving forward
these developers should use Const more
often and less use let less often and
and quit using var and and stay out of
that as much as possible okay so we
talked about the let and the bar the
other thing to think about is in the
older syntax we had arguments let's talk
about that a little bit so let's say for
a minute I'm gonna say constant max is
equal to function and in this case I'm
gonna say a comma B and all I'm gonna do
is if a is greater than B return a
otherwise I'm gonna say return B I'm
going to call right now this particular
function max but I'm going to go ahead
and call the function max with let's say
1 & 2 clearly the result is to no
surprise over there
now I'm gonna say max with a let's say a
4 and a 2 well clearly the result is a 4
no surprise over there but what if I say
over here max with a 4 and a 7 and a 2
well I'm passing three arguments wherein
I have given only two parameters a and B
here but when I run the
notice it still gave us a value of seven
now how in the world can JavaScript do
that well the reason is JavaScript reaps
you like a guest in its house it doesn't
yell at you and say hey you idiot you
shouldn't send three when two is
expected
it'll quietly smile away and accept
everything you give every function
really is a bar art function in
JavaScript actually this is a little
fooling example because notice that in
this case it said seven as an output but
if I send it world clearly that's broken
it's still sending a seven so what's
going on here what's going on here is
that every function is a var art so what
you could do in the past was the
following
you could write code like this you could
say for example you know result is equal
to arguments if you will zero and then
you could return the result when you're
done with it
but with tildes of course you could
write code like this far you could say I
is equal to zero I less than arguments
start lent and then of course you could
say I plus plus and then you could say
for example if result is less than
arguments of I then of course result is
equal to arguments of I and so in other
words in the past arguments was useful
for representing variable arguments so
as you can see in this example the
result was a correct 12 because our
humans represent now there were a few
problems with this code the problem is
couple of things the first problem of
problem 1 is how many parameters does
parameters does this function take and
and the answer to that is who knows
right because you look at this if it
doesn't take any parameters you could
actually take a lot of parameters how
what logic is that how do you describe
this to somebody and saying this
function doesn't take anything so he can
send anything you want to it that is
clearly doesn't make any sense at all
that's one problem the second problem is
what is arguments well that's a very sad
story
so arguments is
our Rhea wannabe so it was not an array
it died before it could become an array
so as a result it just is longing to be
an array but it cannot use it as an
array which is really really sad let's
take a look at an example here if I were
to say in this case arguments and say
instance instance are off let's say
instance off and then I say array notice
the Falls that you get as an output so
that's a really sad isn't it because
arguments is not an array so you cannot
use this an array so what do programmers
normally do they write code to
forcefully convert arguments to an array
which really begins to smell bad in the
code
it's error-prone its verbose more coding
to do what is the answer good news
moving forward quit using arguments
there should be no arguments about it
what you really want to use is the rest
parameter so how do you use a rest
parameter notice I'm gonna start
refactoring this code slowly to start
using rest parameters so the first thing
I'm gonna do here is put three dots
that's the ellipsis to say that this
parameter is a rest parameter and I'll
call it as numbers right here and notice
now we are passing numbers but it's been
indicated as a respirometer what's the
first benefit the first benefit is when
you look at this code it is absolutely
clear how many arguments you can pass
through this you can pass 0 through any
number of arguments because the ellipsis
gives away that particular argument the
second thing is if you look at this here
I'm gonna ask for numbers instance of
array notice false and true while the
arguments is not an array numbers is
actually an array this opens up door for
some really nice things you can actually
do with this so for example I'm a huge
fan of functional style of programming
unfortunately though you cannot say are
humans dart reduce that is not a valid
function as you can see it fails because
reduce does not exist on arguments
because
arguments is not an array on the other
hand you can do numbers start reduce
that is a function available undefined
is not a function belt that will come to
that in a second numbers can be used
with the reduce method very easily so
what is the model of the story the model
of the story is while you could write
code like this you can actually start
using numbers in fact let's do it this
way let's go ahead and copy this over so
in this case instead of using the
arguments the very first thing is it's
easier to refactor the code
so notice everywhere I have arguments I
could use numbers right now so it
becomes a nice stand-in replacement for
it right there
so I could actually use the numbers but
having done that those two look
extremely similar to each other but I
could actually go back to this code and
say well return and in this case I can
say numbers dart reduce and and now I
can provide a bunch of values for this
for example I can say in this case given
a max will say result comma element and
then we can write it in a functional
style for example and I can say if
result is greater than element
well then return the result otherwise
return the element I can write this in a
beautiful functional style as you can
see in this case so that is not possible
with the arguments but we can do this
nicely with the rest parameter so that's
one of the biggest benefits you get out
of this is the rest parameter so what's
the model of the story the model of the
story is the following quit using so
quit using arguments instead instead use
rest which is the dot dot so that is a
much better way to write code moving
forward he want to use rest because a
it's descriptive it's easy to see what
you're passing and B the other benefit
is it is a full-blown array it can
benefit from the methods of the array
you can write it imperatively
you can write it functionally so that's
one benefit you get out of using this so
that's a great benefit you get out of
using the rest but as a opposite to rest
you have what's called as
right operator let's take a look at the
spread operator real quick let's take
one example and play with it
notice in this example I called max with
the values four seven and twelve but on
the other side notice it's a rest
parameter what if I have the following
what if instead of this I have a
constant array is equal to let's say one
two three and I want to call the
function with the array so what if I did
the following what if I said max and
pass the array to it well you clearly
know this is not working properly
because the result should have been a
three not the array one two three so
what just happened what happened was it
passed the entire array has one value to
the numbers if you ask the numbers what
it contains it contains one element
which is the entire array that's not
your intention so what should you do
instead of this what you can do instead
of this is you can call max and say
array square bracket and then you can
pass a zero and then of course you can
say comma 1 and then comma 2 and now you
can see the result is 3 but if you write
code like this you will soon realize you
need another job right this is not a fun
way to write code this is not gonna be
really fun at all imagine writing code
like this for 8 hours a day you're not
going to like the job anymore so what do
you do well the good news is you don't
need another job you just need a better
language and JavaScript now provides
that so max over here and then you can
use the spread operator right there and
you can use the spread so how do you
know it's a rest or a spread notice the
ellipses being used here and the ellipse
is being used here as well if you use
the ellipses on the receiving side it's
the rest have used ellipses on the
sending side it's a spread operator but
what is really cool about it is the
spread is probably one of the coolest
operators available in JavaScript let's
explore this a little bit further it is
not just for rest on the other side you
can actually use it for discrete
parameters as
well let's look at an example let's say
grit equals two function and I'm taking
name one and name two over here and in
this case I'm going to go ahead and
print out let's say you know let's say
hello and then we'll put name one and we
will put name two right here so this is
a little function called greet that we
wrote now what I'm gonna do here is I'm
gonna call greet with let's say Jack
comma Jill and you can see that in this
case I can pass Jack and Jill to this
function but what if I had names equals
two let's say Tom comma Jerry right here
and I want to be able to pass this to
this function well clearly if you try to
say agreed with names that's not going
to work really well you have Tom Jerry
and I'm defined not quite what you
really wanted so what you really wanted
was named square brackets 0 comma name
square bracket 1 and that is also known
as a sad pattern right so we don't want
to do that so what you can do instead is
you can say agreed and then you can
reuse the spread operator on it and
notice how beautiful that is in terms of
how we can pass it that becomes a lot
easier to pass their data so you can use
a spread operator notice that you're
using spread on the side but you don't
have rest on this other side which is
really powerful you can use a spread
anywhere you want to do you take your
collection and spread it but what's
really cool about the spread operator is
you can combine arrays as well so as an
example let's say you have names one
names two names let's say others over
here so I'm gonna have others and in
this case I'm gonna come in here and say
others start join with the little comma
well if I run this code you can see it
said Tom & Jerry so far that's great but
what I can also do here is I can say for
example constant let's say names one
equals two let's say Jack comma Jill and
then I'm gonna say over here oh let's go
ahead and say one more at this point
we'll say constant names two equals two
let's say Tom and
jerry and we will also say let's say
over here a spike but notice what i can
do now
i can call greet but i can send to this
for example names too
well in this case what is it going to do
when I take the greet and past names due
to it well you can see it said hello Tom
Jerry we'll just say and so we can
actually see the difference right here
and it says Tom Jerry and spike on the
other hand I can also say greet like
this but this time around I'm gonna say
names one but I'm going to go ahead and
combine names one and then I'm going to
combine names two and then I'm going to
spread it out so I can actually pass all
of that through and that's pretty darn
powerful as ended you're able to combine
two arrays together into one if you
wanted to but you can also go a little
further if you wanted to for example you
can say agreed and then you can say a
Bob comma J in for example and then
comma and then you can say names one and
you can combine it using that as well so
you can start combining them in any form
or fashion and you can put this together
to communicate and and and combine
either array of data or discrete values
into it you can do that as well
so for example in this case I can take
Bob into a collection I can then bring
in names one into the collection then I
can bring in Jane over here and then I
can also say for example names 2 and I
can bring these together any form or
fashion so you can start combining them
into this so that is a powerful
operation of spread I'll show you one
more power of spread later on but it's
by far one of the most charming
operators I have actually come across in
JavaScript that's pretty darn wonderful
well we saw how we can quit using var
and could using constant as much as
possible we saw how to quit using
arguments and start using rest and
spread well next let's talk about
default parameters why do we care about
default parameters
I take a slightly different view on this
one of the reasons I like a default
parameter is not because you can send
fewer parameters I think it's really
cool because you can easily extend your
functions much more effectively so to
understand this let's take a greet for a
minute and I'm gonna take a name as an
argument and within this I'm gonna
simply say over here hello and then I'm
gonna pass the name over here now I can
call greet and say Jo right here and it
says hello Jo but let's say a few weeks
goes by and you decide to change the
function so that you can add another
parameter for the message well
unfortunately that's a really hard now
because if you go back over here and say
oh let's say message over here and I'm
gonna change this to a message right
here the problem with this code is you
can call greet right now and for any new
calls you can pass the message let's say
hi but what about existing code that's
already there that's gonna be broken a
Jo is no longer happy with you because
you said undefined Jo so that's not
going to be fun at all what do we do
well the beauty is you can actually
specify a default value for exactly that
reason it makes it really easy to extend
existing methods so for example you can
say hello right there and you can see
how you're able to bring that in and you
can use it so this is one nice
capability you're able to bring that in
so if I say greet right here and only
pass Jerry you can see it says hello
Jerry but one of the really interesting
features of the default parameters in
JavaScript is not only can you use a
default parameter but you can also go
here and specify if you will notice I'm
going to change this alight slightly and
I'm gonna put a little dollar and I say
named dart length if you will this is
kind of weird isn't it this is how you
can say hi fight to Jerry so this is a
nice way for you to actually use
barometer in a previous parameter that's
there you can use that so this is really
powerful as you can see where you can
create this particular default value but
also combine it with expressions that
are previously in the parameter list
obviously in this case if you call greet
with Jo and say hello
you will not of course get that
particular feature but you can see in
the other one you're able to use that so
that's a pretty darn powerful feature as
you can see within this particular
default parameters well having said that
though we can use the define parameters
for write but there is one difference we
have to be very careful about and when I
showed this to you you probably will
look at this and say gosh this is nasty
but there's a really good reason why
they did it this way so let's look at
what that is if I go back to this code
now notice I'm calling greet right now
and it said high-five Jerry but if I
call greet right now and if I were to
say in here let's say Jo but I'm gonna
pass a null to it
we know nullus smell we shouldn't really
do this but what does it do well it
simply passes the null so that's a
little nasty don't send on now having
said that though this is a little weird
if I send undefined right here notice
that it actually took the value in this
case of the hi as a parameter so what's
going on why is undefined so special
well there is a really good reason for
this the reason is if you call a method
or call a function if it's returning an
object to you the object may not have
certain properties if the object doesn't
have certain properties those properties
if you try to access them become as
undefined so the beauty is when you
receive an object you can start giving
default values for properties that don't
exist I will show this to you towards
the end of this presentation when I
talked about D structuring which is
pretty amazing how de structuring and
default end and spread all work together
that's really an awesome way to see the
full power of the language so we'll see
this a little later on
well let's move a little forward we
talked about functions pretty much so
far but let's talk about looping values
so let's say we have a to begin with
let's start with names if you will so in
this case I say names equals two let's
say Tom again and Jerry and let's say
spike and I want to iterate over these
values how do you do this in the old
JavaScript in the old JavaScript you
would say far var and you would say I
equal to zero I less than names dart
length I plus plus and then you would
say over here output maybe you would say
something like I and then you would
provide a little dash over here and then
plus names square bracket I now it
worked but nobody ever goes home proud
after writing that code isn't it that's
a really low level code it's melts not
very much fun and nothing to be proud
about well the code has to be a lot more
concise than this how can we really make
that happen well to do this let's try
the enhanced for loop this is a much
better way to write the loops so far and
notice the beautiful word Const over
there now this eye is pretty dangerous
eye is a variable nobody in the right
mind will do it but usually programmers
are not always in the right mind so we
might actually try to change this right
and as a result that could be really a
bad idea well notice I put a word
constant over here that makes the
looping really safe so constant name and
the name is going to come from names
over here and I can simply print the
name right here as you can see notice it
says Tom Jerry and Spike that's awesome
that was really easy to write it but I
know what you're thinking you're saying
all right Venkat that worked all right
but what about the 0 1 & 2 I really
wanted the indexing shouldn't I have
access to that well yeah that would be
really nice let's give it a try how to
write it with the indexing so what I'll
do here
yes I'll say for constant index is equal
to well actually entry off and we will
say names dart and trees and we will
call the entries method and then what we
will do here is we will simply print the
entry out well
isn't that beautiful so you're able to
get the entry value out of it nicely and
as a result you can see how it gave you
an array of the entries you're saying
all right good first step but I really
want to get the index value separate
from the value how do you do that well
here's an idea what we could do here is
we could go back to this code and say
well you give me the entry and I'll say
constant index is equal to + 3 square
bracket 0 and constant name is equal to
n 3 square bracket 1 and then we could
output of course the index value and
then are two dashes and then the name we
could write it like this but something
tells me you're not convinced about it
right because this is a little verbose
you're writing three lines of code
instead of writing one line of code okay
fair enough here's another beautiful
thing you can do you can come to this
code and you can put on a square bracket
and then you can say comma name and you
can put the entry right here and remove
this part this is called the structuring
and be structuring is beautiful as you
can see it's really saving you a little
bit of an effort but you realize well if
you can do this why not simply take this
away from here and simply go up here and
replace the entry and that would work as
well as you can see right here so that
becomes a lot more elegant way to get
the index out of it so this is really
applying two different concepts together
we are using the enhanced for-loop on
one hand but we are also using the B
structuring on the other hand as well
it's an interplay of two different
concepts nicely working together here
and that makes life lot easier as you
can see so
basically what we did we kind of
refactor this into using the D
structuring that's what we are doing at
this point so that's an enhanced
for-loop but wait a minute we're using a
nice little enhanced for-loop but what
in the world is names names is an array
an array is e terrible so we are able to
use this very nicely well but what if I
want to use this for my own purpose for
my own class so a class wheel is just
going to represent the wheel of a car
class car contains a constructor and in
this case what I'm gonna do is say this
got wheels is equal to and I'm gonna
define a bunch of wheels over here so
it's a new wheel right here and we will
create let's say four wheels for this
particular car so I created the four
wheels of this car as you can see now
that I created four wheels what I want
to do is the following I want to come in
here and say constant car equals new car
so we create a new car object then I'm
gonna say far constant wheel off car and
then I want to print out the wheel right
after this so in this case I want to
just print out the wheel well
unfortunately that doesn't work well the
reason it doesn't work is look at the
error it gives you it tells you that car
is not a terrible well how do I make the
car really iterable is the question well
this is where you can create this
beautiful idea of generators and
iterators very nicely but before we talk
about it we have to talk about something
else so we'll come back to this so in
JavaScript if you think about primitives
JavaScript had five primitives in the
past so what were the primitives
javascript had it had number it had a
string it had a boolean then it had a
null and had undefined so these were the
five primitives javascript had well now
javascript has six primitives there is a
new kid on the block
and the new kid on the block is actually
called as symbol so what is a symbol a
symbol is a representation of internal
symbols in the language if you use
languages like Ruby you're familiar with
the idea of symbol not exactly the same
but a similar idea so a symbol can give
you uniqueness now there can be several
purpose of a symbol but one purpose of
symbol airs
remember how JavaScript doesn't have
interfaces in Java in c-sharp and
languages like Java you have concept of
interfaces well because JavaScript
doesn't have interface what if you want
to tell somebody that they they should
implement your method called foo well
the problem is they may already have a
method called foo and how do you know if
it is their method called foo are you
our method called foo to make things
worse remember JavaScript doesn't have
overloading of functions so if they
already have a function foo and you
write a function called foo there's
gonna be a collision between them how do
we deal with it
well javascript found a way to deal with
this rather than introducing interfaces
they decided to introduce unique method
names and so because symbols are unique
method names that have symbol in their
name or unique so one such symbol is
called symbol a dart iterator so the
iterator is a special function and
because it's a symbol it is unique
JavaScript will look for a function with
that name in your object and if your
object contains that function that means
your function your object is e terrible
if your object doesn't have that
function your object is not iterable
well that's exactly what we're gonna use
over here to perform the iteration on
our object so notice when I run the code
it said that car is not eatable
so what am I gonna do now I'm gonna go
back over here and I'm gonna write a
simple dot iterator and
gonna provide a special function called
the iterator function I won't have time
to go into the depth of this but I will
give you a clue and then we'll switch to
something a little simpler I'm gonna
simply say called over here right now
so when I run this code notice the top
it says called and the reason it says
called over there is it looked at the
symbol dot iterator and said AHA you are
supporting an iterator thank you so much
I'm gonna call it if you want to
implement the iterator for yourself that
syntax can become really ugly and nasty
only a few people in the world have
survived their journey well thankfully
you don't have to fight that hard you
can do a lot better but before I show
you what you can do how many of you are
familiar with c-sharp in the room just a
quick show of hands awesome
how many of you are familiar with the
Ruby for example a few ends our hands go
up well both Ruby and c-sharp have this
keyword called yield well that's exactly
what you're gonna use if you understand
what ile doesn't Ruby that's exactly
what L doesn't see sharp that's exactly
what he'll does in JavaScript so notice
what I'll do here I'm gonna say over
here called over here and then I'm gonna
say yield just say a nasty one for now
what is it going to do well first of all
I'm using the yield but you cannot just
used yield anywhere you want to I
mentioned that there's a really ugly
syntax most people don't survive it well
if you're writing that ugly syntax
you're gonna write a lot of code here
you can tell JavaScript compiler you
know what I don't want to go through the
journey why don't you do the work for me
well for that you had to bribe
JavaScript just a little bit and the
bribe you give is called this Asterix so
you cannot use yield in a function
that's not marked with an asterisk so
they go as as buddies they always are
there together so now that I put an
Asterix over there notice it's returning
a value of 1 it's set called and it
returns 1 now notice I'm gonna change
this to called
1 if you will and then I'm gonna repeat
this right here and I'll call this s
called the 2
and return a to notice how it's a it's
called one and call two if you used to
yield in c-sharp this is exactly how C
sharp ield works as well so as you can
see here as you're looping through here
it first comes in the iterator calls the
called one returns one goes back to the
iteration here but then quietly comes
back and resumes over here without
reentering the particular function so
this is like a code or peen if you will
it jumps right in the middle of that
code and execute until the next yield
and then you can see that it goes
further down and ield three right here
and you can see in this case this is
called three and just for our purpose
I'm gonna say in loop right here so you
can see how that's actually going
through in the loop iterating over the
concepts of yield versus the looping
it's able to do this we can leverage
this real leverage this really nicely
now notice what I'm gonna do here well
first of all I'm interested in iterating
over the wheels after all so I can say
for constant wheel off this dot wheels
and then I can simply say over here
yield and then I can yield the wheel to
the collar so in this case you can see
that we are getting one wheel at a time
from the call and that is the four
wheels of the car we are able to get to
it but actually you can do a lot better
than this this is where the power of
yield really comes in rather than doing
it this way when would you write code
like this if you want to control your
own iteration you want to write code
like this however you can also do illed
and then you can simply say this dot
wheels over here and you can also
convert a collection and yield over the
collection as well and that is pretty
darn powerful as you can see this gives
a nice way to generate data from your
collection well that's great so far but
what if I want to iterate over wheels
and I want to iterate over doors
I want to iterate over
seeds what have you well this of course
is not going to help us because the
symbol dart iterator gives one iteration
over the collection you want multiple
types of iterators what gifts well here
comes the beauty you can simply go to
this code and you can say wheels over
here let's call this as d wheels for the
white confusion so doing wheels and I
simply come down here and say the wheels
and notice how in this case D wheels can
be the function that I can start
iterating over here in this code for the
iteration purpose and I can start doing
that very nicely as you can see right
here so in this case as you see the
wheels is a function but I turned the
function into a generator by sprinkling
a star in front of it and as a result
that becomes a generator function as a
result I can have yet another function
called the doors if you will and the
doors can do whatever it wants to do if
you want to iterate over doors you can
call the doors you read over the wheels
you can call the wheels and so on so
this becomes a really nice way for you
to use this generator and so not only
can you use an elegant for loop you can
also use elegant for loop on your own
classes as well by implementing nice
little generators well the next thing I
want to talk about is arrow functions
we'll talk about the structure of arrow
functions and then we'll talk about some
gotchas with it let's say we have a
greet is equal to function in this case
I'm gonna take a name over here as a
parameter and then of course I'm gonna
say let's say hello dollar name right
here in this case I can call greet and
pass Jane over here and you can see that
it says hello Jane well this is a
regular function I've written right here
but what I can do here is we can use an
arrow function so let's talk about arrow
function arrow function structure is as
follows you have a parenthesis parameter
list fat arrow as they can call it
and then of course this is the same as
you use in c-sharp and then you write a
single line body of the function and so
this becomes the structure of an arrow
function now the parentheses is optional
so it's optional if the parameter list
has only one parameter so if you don't
have any parameter or you have more than
one you're required to put a parenthesis
but if you don't have anything other
than one parameter you can let go of it
so how do we write this here in here
constant greet is equal to named arrow
and then I can simply say over here
output hello and then a dollar name as
you can see so we are using an arrow
function rather than writing a regular
function so this becomes a very concise
way of writing the code but
unfortunately though this is easy said
than done the problem is you cannot just
simply use an arrow function anywhere
there is a function that's a really a
slippery slope we're gonna get hurt if
you do that well why is that such a big
problem for this we have to understand
the scoping now let's talk about scoping
let's say you know kind languages use
what is called lexical scoping so what
is lexical scoping lexical scoping is
where you can eyeball the code eyeball
the code are to find variables or to
bind to this is a very easy way to think
about it you can just eyeball the code
and say oh look the code is here I'm
gonna look around that's a variable I'm
gonna use that's lexical scoping now on
the other hand hard languages languages
so what do they do use dynamic scoping
so what is dynamic scoping a variable is
bound to what the caller sense well this
is really hard why because you don't
know who the caller is when you look at
the code when they send the data they
send you they are
you to bind to now then comes along evil
languages use both lexical scoping and
dynamic scoping is anyone aware of such
an evil language right so this is why
javascript is pure evil because it uses
both lexical scoping and the dynamic
scoping we gotta be extremely careful
about this so let's understand why this
is a big deal to understand this let's
take a look at an example of a function
which is gonna use multiple different
scopes in here so we can appreciate this
a little bit better so what I'm gonna do
here is create a constant greet is equal
to let's go ahead and say function name
we'll call this as greet 1 actually
let's call it as F 1 and I'm gonna pass
a value end to this and I'm gonna just
print the value and now I'm gonna say
constant F 1 is equal to n and then I'm
going to over here print the value of n
notice that F 1 and F 2 are very similar
to each other in what they do but one is
written as a regular function the other
is returned as a narrow function now I'm
gonna call F 1 with a 7
I'm gonna call F 2 with the 7 no
surprises over here both of them are the
parameters being passed in however
there's something we need to keep in
mind a regular function regular and
anonymous functions use lexical scoping
for all non parameters except this and
arguments this is one of the really sad
stories about how JavaScript works
javascript uses lexical scoping for
everything except for this and arguments
so as a result as you can see here I'm
gonna say it this dart something is
equal to 4 now I come in here and say
this dot something and
same thing I'm gonna do over here as
well but we'll do that in just a minute
now notice in here I'm gonna go ahead
and call this with the function f1 we
know what NS its a local variable but
what is this unfortunately this is
dynamically scoped so when I run this
code it says undefined
the reason it says undefined is that the
f1 is going to receive that this so if I
said over here let's say for a minute if
I were to say over here f1 a dart call
and I'm gonna say something
AHA and then I pass the value of seven
notice in the second call over here it
actually says aha
and the reason is the caller sends that
this as a parameter to that function
which is pretty sad as you can see right
here so in this case this and arguments
are going to use so what are the dissing
arguments do this end arguments use
dynamic as a dynamic scoping right so
this is basically how this works this is
dynamic scoping if I know how to type
that so dynamic scoping is what they use
for dissing arguments on the other hand
our arrow functions use lexical scoping
for all non parameter parameters so they
consistently use lexical scoping for
everything so as a result semantically
they are very different from one another
as you can see in this example if I go
back to this code and if I take this one
and put it into f2 when I run the code
notice f2 says four and not undefined in
the first place in fact if you go back
over here and say F 2 dot call and I say
something and then aha and then of
course comma 7 well guess what it makes
no sense to use call
on this it will not use AHA because the
this is never bound by an arrow function
so what's the model of the story
the model of the story is no the
semantics a semantical difference right
difference between between arrow
functions and non arrow functions so
that's the first thing the second thing
to keep in mind as given this arrow
functions use a lexical scope so for all
variables that are not parameters
so let's infer something from that it
makes zero sense to use arrow function
as method of a class just think about
that for a minute
right why would you ever want to do that
because if you make an arrow function a
method of a class that this will be
bound to whatever is outside of the
class and so when you call the method
the object will not be bound to the
object on which the method is attached
to it will be something else it makes no
sense to do that
so just because arrow functions are cute
doesn't mean we use them all the time we
have to really understand the semantical
difference between an arrow function and
a regular function otherwise we'll get
really hurt by it so we have to be very
careful about it I want to show you
three other concepts before we are done
here and and this is by for a pretty
nice interesting feature that JavaScript
has added and that is template literals
you saw me do this already so what you
can do here is suppose you had a
constant name equals to Jane well you
could write code like this you could say
hello and then plus and then you could
say name like this but this is so boring
well instead of doing it this way you
could actually do a backtick hello
dollar name and you can write a template
literal notice carefully the backtick
why a backtick
the single court and double court
already have meaning in JavaScript
they are just literals they cannot
change the rule of the game suddenly
because backward compatibility is very
important for Java so at our script so
as a result they said we're gonna use a
new symbol called a back take this
becomes what's called a template literal
and as a result you can embed
expressions in here for example hello
name is of length for example named dart
length as you can see and you're able to
write it that way as well so you can see
that you are able to use the expressions
here as well and you can use these
things called template order all but I'm
gonna show you an object literal and
when I show this to you the way I'm
gonna show it to you you probably will
get angry as I did but there's a really
good use for it in the structuring so
we'll talk about that after I show you
the nasty code let's say for a minute I
have a constant the name equal to Sam
right here I also have a constant the
age is equal to 2 now I want to say a
constant Sam equal to named colon the
name and then age colon the age so this
shouldn't be of any surprise at all to
you so I'm printing Sam right here well
this is great but then notice I could
just use age over here then I could use
age over here and when I run the code it
works but what is this we are dealing
with right now this age is a property
this age is a local variable this is
where an object literal comes in if the
name of the property is the same as the
name of a local variable
you can't quietly omit that and write
the code like this so this becomes a
really easy way to take objects and
create them from existing variables so
similarly if this was called as name I
can call this as name as well or what I
can do here is I can quietly remove this
part
and I can write the code like this so
the key here is you should really watch
out for this curly that is sitting right
here now given this this is object
literal you're constructing there is
also what is called be structuring
before we talk about be structuring I
want you to look at that word
structuring let's change the word
structuring to something else let's call
it construction what is construction
construction is where you create an
object from data well
structuring our construction is you
create an object from data be
construction or being structuring is the
reverse of it you create variables from
an object so notice what I'm gonna do
here I'm gonna take this object and in
this case let's take the same object if
you will and let's say the same object
contains the name called Sam and we also
have an age let's say is 2 but I want to
get this variable back from the caller
how do I do that so notice I can say
constant and in this case I can say the
name equal to Sam dot name I can say
constant the age equal to Sam dot H then
it can print out here
well the name and then I can also print
out the age as well this is an old-style
boring code we can write it like this
but I realize quickly if I'm all them
doing is d structuring why can't we do
this a little bit more elegantly
so notice constant what is the name of
the variable the name but where does the
value come forward from the name if you
will and similarly the age is the
property the age is the variable equal
to Sam I'm able to do be structuring at
this point now if the syntax is a little
confusing I'll give you a clue to make
it a bit easier for you rather than
seeing this as an assignment look at
this as pattern matching what does that
really mean you're saying
on the right side I have name : Sam and
I also have H :
or to now apply pattern matching name
named Sam the name aha I'm gonna sign
the name - Sam age is age D age is - so
this is a pattern matching that's what
you're really doing in this case so you
are saying look what's on the right and
look what's on the left and whatever has
come and keep it whatever it is defined
here as a variable where is a constant
over here literal over here assigned to
it as a pattern matching so that is
basically what's happening in the syntax
he's a pattern matching now why is this
such a cool thing the reason this is the
cool thing is I'll show you one more
thing what you can do with this now
let's write a function called print it
now the printed function says person and
within this function what am I going to
do let's say we have a height and I
would say height is 100 whatever that
means
but I'm gonna say print out we could say
person's name earth and then I'm gonna
say a person dot name and let's say name
and then would say and H s and then
we'll say person dot H if you look at
this code real quick right here this is
using the person's name and person's age
no surprise over there now what I'm
gonna do here is in this case I'm going
to call print it and pass Sam to it
while that worked the person's name is
Sam and ages two but notice I don't care
about height I don't care about weight
whatever that value is it doesn't really
matter to me but what I'm really looking
for is name an age if that's all I want
here's a what I can do right constant
name is equal to person dot name okay
and then constant age is equal to person
dot age okay now I can use a name here I
can use an edge here
well only a little bit better we remove
the clutter just a little bit oh wait a
minute we could use object D structuring
isn't it so why not simply say over here
constant name comma age is equal to
person now that would really eliminate
that ugly syntax after all well wait a
minute if you can do that why not just
elevate this all the way up to here
isn't that beautiful
so you can actually do the D structuring
on entry to the parameter so what desay
says when an object is being passed on
the other side just take the name and
age alone leave out the rest of the
things that is D structuring right there
when you are receiving the data just
like I did however we factored it
through some stages it becomes really
easy to understand if you go through the
steps of refactoring it that really ties
the idea in our mind really well where
we are just saying extract the name
extract the age and leave out the height
and weight or other properties I don't
care about it and I'll show you one last
thing before we are done with this
notice in here I'm gonna print out Sam
now I want to create an older Sam is
equal to now I say name is Sam dot name
age is Sam dart age plus one height is
Sam dart height and weight is Sam dart
weight this is also known as bad idea
isn't it why is this such a bad idea
well notice in here Sam is the same as
Sam was before we are not mutating Sam
which is a good news but unfortunately
here notice that in this particular case
I had to copy every single property in
here so the age is going to be Sam dot h
plus one and so on this is a sad story
isn't it the age is different everything
of the same why is this a bad idea well
tomorrow Sam gets a Facebook ID or a
Twitter account right so in this case
you're gonna say
whatever Sam's ID is now the code is
broken isn't it because you have to come
here and say , Twitter is equal to Sam
dar Twitter nobody wants to write code
like that that's stupid isn't it well
the good news is you don't have to what
you can do instead is you can simply
come here and say the age is different
and I've seen this facility in languages
like Elm for example so what you can do
here is you can simply say Sam , so
notice how beautifully you are using the
spread operator to copy everything from
the object you probably have seen this
in redux Redux uses this quite a bit to
make copies of objects and and the
spread operator is beautifully in here
where you can simply say take everything
from sam and only give me a new value
for age and so as a result the height
and weight and the name all got copied
over pretty nicely so the good news is
modern JavaScript is a lot better than
the JavaScript that tormented once us
once upon a time a lot of beautiful
features they introduced these from
different languages like for example
parts of c-sharp Ruby Python Java so
many features and so many different
languages have influenced this and I
think they have done a remarkable job so
if you're interested in the code
examples you can download them from my
website if you're interested in the book
I mentioned feel free to take a look at
that as well hope that was useful thank
you
[Applause]